je voulais un petit et à huy alors que
tu rencontres des parents tu vas les
adorer 60 beaucoup à fabas ça te dirait
de d'aller à la baule le week-end
prochain j'en peux plus comment je suis
vraiment désolé mais je crois que je ne
mérite pas je comprends pas je suis
vraiment désolé mais je te mérite pas tu
vas pas à me faire le coup de tes trop
bien pour moi quand même oui tu as
raison en vérité pas mon type de mec tu
me plais pas tu vois j'aimerais bien
mais tu m'ennuie
en fait le mec le plus cher au monde a
privé la barre et j'irai pas la bonne
chez tes parents je vais rentrer chez
moi plus tôt mais je comprends pas mais
qu'est ce que tu comprends pas rater pas
ont-ils donné n'était pas mon team
devient active et je suis pas un
amoureux de l'amour je te jure
non mais ça n'a rien à voir je m'en fous
du soin d'un bonne case ou pas tu vois
je m'en fou tout ce que c'est que tu me
fais chier je suis allé diouf et chez à
redon compris côté
j'ai compris charles était bien voir le
jour tu as mal au dos je suis mort